あの九はこのシレンディキョの三番目
心をどのように観察するかっていうこと
チッッターヌパッサナーと読むんですね
カ
タンチャパナビッケウェービッコーチッティエチッターヌパッシーヴィハルティイダビッケウェービッコーサラガムワチッタンスラガムチッタントゥパジャナティヴィタ
ガムワチッタングヴィタガムチッタントゥパジャナティサドサンガムワチッタンスドサンチッタントゥパジャナティヴィータドサンガムワチッタングヴィータドサンチッタントゥパジャナティ
サ
モハンガムワチッタンスモハンチッタントゥパジャナティヴィータモハンチワチッタングヴィータモハンチッタントゥパジャナティサンキッタングチッタンスサンキッ
タングチッタントゥパジャナティヴィッキッタングワチッタングヴィッキッタングチッタントゥパジャナティマハッガタングワチッタングマハッガタングチッタントゥパ
ジャナティアマハッガタングワチッタングアマハッガタングチッタントゥパジャナティ
サ
ウッタラングワチッタングサウッタランチッタントゥパジャナティアヌッタランチュワチッタングアヌッタランチッタントゥパジャナティサマヒタングワチッタングサ
マヒタングチッタントゥパジャナティアサマヒタングワチッタングアサマヒタングチッタントゥパジャナティヴィムッタングワチッタングヴィムッタングチッタントゥパ
ジャナティアヴィムッタングワチッタングアヴィムッタングチッタントゥパジャナティ
というところで で 瞑想を始める人々は
最初は体から始まるんですね
で いわゆる物体というかね
まあ命あるものでなきゃダメですけどね
まあ自分の体やら呼吸やら歩くことやら息やら
そういうところから始まると
最初はそうでないとなかなか心っていうのは成長していけないんだから
もうたいていして瞑想っていうのはできるものではありません
で それから体の瞑想として
またいろんなものを付け加え
例えば体は物質に分けて
小さいカーブに分けてみるとか
あるいはこの死体ですね
それから体の中身部品を三十二に分けて
三十二の不浄なもの あまり格好いい美しいものではないと
その意味で観察するんですね
で そのだけでもかなり違いが生まれるんですね
我々はすごいかっこいいんだとか
美しいんだとか 美人だとかね
で いろんなことを言いますけど
それはどこに存在するかと
で 結局あるのは皮膚やら髪の毛やら体の毛やらね
腸やら異物やら大便 小便とかね
まあそういう風に物ではないかと
骨やら骨髄やらね 三十二に分けてみるんですね
それは別に医学的な厳密に分け方とかね
そんな考え方はまるっきりない
一般の人々の知識に乗ってあげましょうとかね
合わせましょうとか そうでないと立場がないんですよという見えはないんです
ただ単に人間の感情というかね
心の見方を変えたいだけなんですね
ですから まあこのケースローマナカダンタジャトタチュンサンナハルアッティアッティミンジャワッカンハダヤカナンキロマガンペカンパッパサンという三十二がありまし
て
その三十二に分けてみると
で 一つ部品見ても別に男でもないし女でもないし
例えばもう心臓を男か女か綺麗か汚いかと
もうどっちでもない ただの部品であって
いや 異物は何ですかね
胃の中に入ってるものは
それは男ですか？女ですかね
まあどちらでもね 綺麗ですか？汚いですか？と
まあ大体はまあ醜い 汚いということにはなります
見たくはないんだと で
そういう風に見ると この世の中に対して
まあ今までやったいろんな概念
いろんな囚われ いろんな引っかかったもの全部綺麗さっぱり破れて消えてしまうんですね
それ綺麗さっぱり破れて消えてしまうためには
もう確かにこの体にこれしかないんだと
だから自分の体だけじゃなくて
他の人を見ても これも髪の毛や体の毛
皮膚 骨 骨髄 心臓 腎臓 それから腸
異物 大便 小便 血液 それからまたいくつかありますけどね
そういうものの塊ですよと
そういうものを組み立ててできているものですと
他の人を見ても同じこと
他の人見ても同じこと
そうやって本気になって見られる人だったら
心の中で何の感情というよりも
何のこだわりも 何の引っかかることも何もなく
心はすごく自由になってしまうので
世の中の概念に引っかからないんですね
そうすると 心理の世界を理解することができるんですね
心理っていうのは まあそういう
すごいこの科学者見ている世界と同じなんですね
例えばまあ化学とか物理学の人とかね
とことん厳密に物質を研究しちゃうと
見つかるのは原子だけであろうし
原子の中でもあるのはいろいろ素粒子だけであろうし
そちらに何ものもないんですね
ただの同じ そこで金も銀も存在しないんですね
素粒子とか原子として物事を見るならば
で それはまたすごい勢いで変化しているものだけであって
すべて消えちゃうんですね
幻覚の世界っていうのは
ですから 心理の世界っていうのは
そのようにこの何もない世界といえば何もない世界であって
それはただ言葉だけのことなんですけど
別にこのもう天やら神やらね
精神やら魂やらそういうふうなものの世界ではありません
それは本当の心理の世界なんですね
分解して分解して 客観的に徹底的に見ると
見つかるのはもう単なるもうものすごい勢いで変化していく
もういくつかのエネルギーの流れだけなんですね
で そこまでは体のこと
物質として体のことを観察すると出てきてわかっていて
心は大変安らぎになるんです
それで次にヴェーダナーという感覚というかね
感受性というかね 感じることに入るんですね
だいたい人々は私がいるんだとか
魂があるんだとかね 私が偉いんだとかね
ほとんど思うのはこの感覚なんですね
人生は楽しいんだとかね
人生は苦しいんだとかね
いろんなことを言うんですけど
それはもう一応体で感じて言ってることなんですね
では体で何を感じるかと
そんなに魂があって ずっと永久的に喜悦感を感じ続けているんですかとかね
苦しみは他の宗教で言ってるような苦しみは一時的なものであって
本来魂はサッチットアーナンダンというサット
リアルであって 確固たるものであって
チットっていうのは心っていうことで
いわゆる考える知識の主体であって
知恵の主体であって アーナンダンというのは何でしたっけ
喜び 喜悦感であると だから本当の魂っていうのは
そういう三特色持っているものだと
サット それこそ本物であって
実体としてあるものだと
チットっていうのは知る機械機能がもう魂であると
で 魂自体がもうアーナンダン
喜びしか何も感覚を持ってないと
というと みんなこの余計な外に
魂に 周りについている
この苦しみやらね 区別感やら
それ全部ヨーガをでもって瞑想でもってなんとか取り払って
この本来のもう真たるこの喜悦感のみある魂になろうではないかというふうに頑張ったりするんだけどね
で そういう世界ではありません
そんなものはいくら探しても見つからないんです
で 見つかった人もいません
いろんな人は瞑想したんだという経験は記録しているんだけど
サッチターナンダン見つかった人は一人いません
インド文化の世界では
ただ言うだけで 完全に悟りましたというはっきりと証言しているのは仏教の世界だけなんです
で ずるずるともうどうかあっちこっち誰でも誰でも定る悟ると
それまた本物であって
嘘でも何でもない ですから
まあ神秘体験者がいっぱいいますけどね
アートマンを体験した人は一人もいません
神秘体験というのは幻覚やとのかのことなど仏教はもう捨ててるんですね
心のカラクリだと 心っていうのはいつでも幻覚作るんですね
今も我々の心は幻覚作りっぱなしなんですね
その幻覚は他の人の幻覚と似ているんだから
我々は正気だと勘違いしているんですね
私はバラの花を見て これ綺麗な花だなと言ったら
みんなあーそうですねと
だからみんなの幻覚同じだからあ
正気だと もし私はバラの花を見て他のこと
これなんか毒蛇みたいな
あるいはアンコウみたいなグロテスクですねと言ったら
あ あんたちょっとおかしいと
ただそれだけのことで
バラの花でもすごいグロテスクだと見ると見られますよ
すごいグロテスクなものだと
ものすごい美しいものだと見ると
それもその通りで見えちゃうし
グロテスクだと見るとそのように見えるし
ですから 私はバラの花を見てすごいグロテスクだと
アンコウの顔みたいんだと言ったら
あ やっぱりこの人ちょっとおかしいんだと
と言うでしょう で なぜそう言いますかというと
たくさん人々の幻覚と似てないんだからなんです
我々はいろんな人に あの人病気で
あの人頭狂ってるんだというのは
その人に見える幻覚 我々に見えないからだけなんですね
であのちょっと頭がおかしくなっちゃうと
それもあの感情の 感情も誰でも持ってますけど
あので 脳のコントロールがなくなったりする場合ありますね
で 人は嫌だと思うのは誰にでもあります
相手が嫌だと あるんだけど
脳のコントロールを失っちゃったら
相手が嫌だではなくて
すごく醜く見えちゃうんですね
顔がものすごい変になってとかね
檻のように色々牙が出たりとかね
あるいはベロがもうすごく伸びているとかね
あるいは口からウジ虫が出ているとかね
そういう風に見えたりするんです
で あの喋ってみてください
そういう人々と もし信頼すれば全部言うんで
信頼しないと言わないんです
この精神的な あの ちょっと我々はおかしいという人々が
で あの信頼したら 自分にはそういう風に見えるんだと
で ある人の話を聞くと
その人はあの ちょっと暴力的で
もう人をぶん殴ったり
突然ぶん殴ったりする
すごく仲良くニコニコで喋ってて
いきなり相手をぶん殴ったりして
それから治療を色々受けたりもしましたけど
で まあ彼が私とはかなり仲良しで
で 私にはこう言うんですね
本当は何々さんだとと一緒によく喋っていたんだと
突然その人はものすごいもう気持ち悪い
恐ろしい化け物になってしまったと
なんか攻撃かけてくる
恐ろしい化け物になってしまって
気持ち悪くてぶん殴っちゃったと
その時に その人は決して悪いことをやっているわけじゃなく
すごい勇気のあるいい子でしたからね
性格としては だから逃げるんじゃなくて
まあ男ですだし 逃げるんじゃなくてやっつけてやっちゃったんです
恐ろしい化け物 でも他の人から見れば
この人はもうこの人と喋っていて
いきなりその人をぶん殴ったんだから
この人は精神的な病気でおかしいと
で 病院に連れて行かなくちゃいけないってことになって
病院に連れて行って 薬で一応抑えられてるだけで
本人それも分かってるんです
ものすごく 自分は今は薬で
あの 一応そういう風にならないように抑えられているんだと頭を
そうでないともう見えますよ
突然 何のことなく言うんで
でもそれはもしかすると誰にも言ったことないと思いますけど
神経の医者にも行ったことないと思いますけど
私とは仲がいいんだからね
そう言います なぜ私と言ったんですか？って
私はその人を病気だと思ってないんだからね
誰が病気で誰が病気じゃないかと言えますかね
言えないでしょうに ですから
この大勢の人々に見える幻覚は見えないとおかしいというだけで
だから例えば現代 今の子供たちのもうファッションの超格好いいと言っちゃうと
すごい進んでるんだと思う
勘違いするし 汚いと醜いと言ったら
まあ変な人だと っていうだけのことなんですね
だからこれが美しい これが美しくないとかね
ある時期すごい美しいと格好いいとかっこいいと言ってきたデザインが
一年経つと まあ古くてあんなかっこ悪いものをよくも着くんですねと平気で言うでしょう
で 二十年ぐらい前にね
男性のズボンの下の方がね
すごく広げてあったんですね
あの 何 何て言う その当時はベルボトムと言ったんだけどね
まあ当時はそれすごいかっこよかったんです
今同じくあのズボンの下のところはもうすごく広げて
何かつけちゃったら まあかっこ悪いと言うでしょうね
そのように まあヨーロッパではね
何と言いますか 髪の毛を全部周りは全部剃って
真ん中まで何かトスみたいに
うん？パンク え？ モヒカンじゃなくてパンク
で あんなものはかっこいいんですよ
だからそういうことをやっている人々に
普通の自然の髪の毛でいると
あんた方は何なのかと
進んでないんだと だからどちらですかね
だからそうやって あの幻覚なんですね
だから大勢の人が同じ幻覚を作ると正気
みんな作ってる幻覚と違う幻覚作ると正気ではありませんと
幻覚だからずっと人間のもう好き嫌いも変わっていくんですね
ある時期流行ってる流行ってる歌は
ある時期はもうつまらないと
だんご3兄弟の歌はもういきなりもう爆発的に流行ってしまって
まあまあ子供たちにとってはすごくこれ気持ちよく映ってしまったんだけど
それで商売やる連中がもういきなりこれで儲けようと
いきなり出すと出てしまっちゃって
もうこれで大人が商売にしたと思う
これで子供たちはもうそれはないと言ったらそれで終わりと
[笑い]子供それなりにかなり学習しているみたいですけどね
で 今はあまり全然面白くないと
でもその時はそうではなかったんですね
ですから ある時は綺麗という歌は
ある時ある時はそうではないと
本当にそうではなくなっちゃうんですよ
面白くないと感じるんです
では何でしょうかね もし耳がある歌を聴いてすごい感動したならば
いつでもその歌を聴いたら感動するはずなんだ
だから感動っていうのは幻覚なんですね
だから違う幻覚も作られるということ
だからみんなワイワイと歌っている歌を聴いて
あ つまらない歌だと気持ち悪いんだと一人の人だけ言っちゃうと
その人は正気じゃないとみんな言っちゃうんです
ね だいたいそういうふうな世界なんですね
だから正気になりたくて
みんな大勢の人が何を考えて何を感じているかといって
それに合わせる 自分の幻覚を
それも可能なんです だからあのパン頭している人もかっこいいと思えば
もうかっこよく見えちゃうんです
かっこ悪いと思えばかっこ悪いように見えるし
例えば男性が耳に 何て言いますかね
あのイヤリングつけたりとかね
もう体中アクセサリーつけたりしちゃうと
いきなり男はそんなことやっていなかったんだからな
変な男やとと思ったり
それも幻覚であって またみんなやり始めたら
あ これ流行ってるんだと
もう現代的だと と思ってしまえば
あ かっこいいと もうかっこよく見えちゃうんですね
それで そういうことだから
この我々の生き方というのは
ずっと幻覚だけ作って
幻覚から幻覚へと 幻覚だからもういつでも変化できる
変えることできる 実際の認識だったら変えられないはずなんです
実際本当のものだったら
でも変えてしまっちゃうんですね
そういうことだから それは心の働き
だからバラの花見て これはあんこの顔と同じですよと言うことも可能であるし
すごい美しいものだということも可能であるし
これはものすごい光り輝いている
ものすごい花火のような美しいものやと思うことも可能なんですね
だからなんでその幻覚は大事にしますかと
だから心の体の中で魂が光り輝いているんだと頭に言ってあげれば
まずわからない じゃああんたこういうこういう仕来りで
こういうこういう瞑想しなさいと言ったら
もう体の中ですごい光り輝いている魂が見えてくるんです
それは事実だと どうやって証明できますかね
自分の魂も真の魂と一体になりましたとかね
ずっとそれで暗示かけてかけてかけてから瞑想を始めたら
いとも簡単にそういう経験
体験することはできます
でもその人々は単なる幻覚作ってるだけ
あのポケモンカードで遊んでいる子供とは何の変わりもないんです
で ポケモンカードで遊んでいる子供たちには
本当にポケモンというのは生き物なんです
あるカードを出しちゃったらものすごいパワーアップになったり
あるカード出したら麻痺したりするんですよ
ポケモンでいろいろ戦わされたりするんだからね
一人の子供がカード出す
それでもう一人の子供はそれにもっとパワーのあるポケモンを出しちゃうと
こちら負けちゃうでしょうね
それでパワー計算するんだからね
向こうは8で こちら6だからこちらマイナス2でしょうね
そこでもうプラス6のカードであったら出しちゃえばこちらは8になる可能性ありますけど
ポケモン同士の相性もありますね
そこでプラス6だったところで
ポケモン同士の相性悪くて
あのマイナス2 プラス2をマイナス2やってプラス4になるかもしれません
そうすると相手はまだ力強いんですね
それでこの子供がもし相手を麻痺するカードを持ってるんだったら
これ出すと だったら向こうは麻痺しちゃうんですね
力はあるんだけど それで2回有効だったら2回こちらが勝つんです
安いカードで まあそうやってもうまあ計算しながら子供たちよく元気で頑張ってやってますけど
で もうカードに全部説明書いてるし
どちらとどちらと相性がいいんですか？とかね
進化させたりもするし
で ものすごい複雑なんですけどね
じゃあその子供たちには
そのポケモンっていうのは本当にその通りで生きてるものなんですよ
違うものいたら怒られるんです
何が進化やと ただのカードではないかと言ったら
いえ 違いますよと これぐらい点数持ってこれぐらい点数でこれぐらい敵を倒したから
こういう風に進化するんだと
進化したらパワーがこれぐらいですよと
もうとことん言っちゃいますからね
だから そういう子供の精神状態とは変わりがないんです
その子供もカード読んでポケモンのストーリーいっぱい読んで読んで読んで
その世界に入り込んじゃうんでしょうし
ですから神が一体とかね
神を体験とかね イエス様をもう見ましたとかね
いろんなこと言いますけど
それはずーっと頭に暗示かけて暗示かけて
このカトリック教のあのモンクスという神父さんたちがいるんですね
で 彼らが瞑想もしますけどね
彼らの瞑想っていうのは
そうやって何かを姿を見たくて見たくて
そればっかり念じるんですね
大体もう 1万人  2万人に一人ぐらいに見える現象っていうのは
イエス見えちゃうんですよ
十字架には釘打ってるよ
姿で かわいそうにイエスがずっと釘打ったまんまでいるんですかね
それぐらい論理は使いません
だから確かによえに神様がいるんだと
本人にはイエスが十字架で釘を打たれて血を流しながら大変苦しみを味わって
なんとか冠 とげ付いてる冠かぶってるような
見えるんですね 堂々と目の前で
あれ見えたんだからって
どう考えてもイエスがもう釘打って打たれて殺されたのはほんの瞬間の出来事で
1日2日しかいなかったしね
十字架で それで死んじゃったらね
遺体を処分しましたし
で それ隠して またあっちこっち現れたんだとかね
ストーリーまで作りましたし
だからって ああいう風に
もし本物のイエス見えたならば
テキストによると彼が天国にいるんですね
父親と一緒に その姿で見えるでしょうね
それだったら でもそれは人間には想像できないんです
神のことも想像できないでしょう
ミケランジェロぐらいですね
神を書いたのは 本当は書いてはいけないんです
で それであの神を頭でイメージできませんから
神と一緒にいるイエス様のイメージもできないんですね
だからイメージできるのは人間でいた歴史的に起きた出来事なんですね
それはもうイメージできる
だから瞑想するとそれ見えちゃう
マリア見える連中にみんなにこの赤ちゃん抱っこしてるんですね
何なのかと あれは マリーがずっと赤ちゃんを抱っこしてるんですかね
だからそういうことをほんのちょっとの論理で考えちゃうと
あんたいい加減にせんかと
薬でも飲みなさいと言いたくなるんでしょうし
でもそうしないのは 世の中の人々はいかに頭がおかしくて狂ってるかっていうこと
みんな病気なんです みんな幻覚の中にいるんですね
幻覚を破ってしまえば
ほんの単純な論理で ほんの単純な論理で壊されるんです
それで問題は あの そういう何を言おうとも
結局ここに私がいて 私が物事を認識している
目でものを見て感じる
耳で音を聞いて感じる
舌で何か触れたら ところで味として感じる
体で感じると 頭でも感じると
楽しみとかね 喜びとか悲しみとかね
頭では感じる だから感じるということは
一番肝心なことなんです
そんな神がいるかいないかではなくて
そういうことで じゃあ具体的に我々の感覚って何ですかと
はっきりと見るとなんですかというと
痛みがある 苦しみ ドゥッカ・ヴェーダナ
スカ・ヴェーダナ 楽しみの感じがある
それから不幸 浮楽の感覚があると
それ私にもそれがあって
他の人々にもそれがあると
それは変わらないんです
それは違うと言えません
もしジーザスにドゥッカ・ヴェーダナなかったならば
十字架に首 釘刺しに刺されちゃってかわいそうでもったいないんですね
何の痛みも痒くもないんだから
あれは痛いんだからこそ受難というんですよ
神の子だったら痛くないはずでしょうしね
でもはっきりと痛いと
その前提で その殺されたことを宗教的に解釈するんですね
歴史的に見れば 彼を殺されただけのことですけどね
憎しみで で そういうことはね
伝統を壊そうとすると
この保守主義の人々っていうのはいつでも人殺しやってるんです
いまだに今も世の中で保守主義の連中がね
ずっと人殺しやっている
共産主義を応援した人々は
その主義のために他の人を殺してきましたし
西洋もいまだに他の人々をもう殺しちゃうし
サルビア人も殺されるし
チェチェンでももう殺されちゃうし
それはもう自分の主義に基づいている
チェチェン人たちが自分がイスラム教だからソ連人を殺してやるぞということで
テロをやったり ソ連もソ連人も怒って
あんたがた何者かということで殺してやる
お互いに戦争をやってるし
ですから 人殺しっていうのは
まぁ神様の子でなくても
そういう概念に基づいて世の中で起きていることなんですけど
それは普遍的に見られないんですね
人類にいまだに ですから
このそちらにおけるというのは
そういうことだけのことなんですけど
とにかく苦しい ドゥッカ・ヴェーダナ
苦しいという感覚 体にある
痛いという気持ち悪い感覚
それから気持ちいいという感覚がある
それから普通に気持ち悪いでもいいでもない
ただ自分の体を感じているという感覚があります
それもドゥッカかスカかアドゥッカマスカ
パーリ語でその 3つの言葉なんですけどね
その分析も人によって違いますよ
ですから 感覚にはお釈迦様
3つの言葉使ってますけど
うーん まあそれほど厳密にしがみついて概念にしがみつくこともやっぱり否定しているんですね
で なぜかというと ある人がスカだと楽だという感覚に
他の人は別に楽だと言わない可能性あります
そういうのも対象 比較的なんですね
例えばすごいものすごい高級的な美味しいものを食べている人が
ごく普通の何か食べるようになったところで
こんなものは食べられないんだと
美味しくもないんだと
まずいんだという可能性はあるでしょう
そうすると 牛の肉を食べてた人が
これすごい高い 2万円の皿の上に入れて
大変なこのまた 1万 2万ぐらいのフォークで切って牛の肉を食べると
そういう人はどこかへインドネシアにでも行ったところで
コウモリの丸焼き食べなくちゃいけなくなっちゃったと
それも木の枝 枝にコウモリを刺して
普通の薪でもう焼いて
そのまま食べると 言うと食べられないんですね
あるいはネズミの丸焼き
で もう食べられないでしょうね
もし強引に食べられたら
その人はすごい苦しみを味わっちゃうんです
これ拷問だと訴える可能性もあります
それだと でも インドネシアのそこら辺でこのコウモリを丸焼きにして食べる人やらね
ネズミを丸焼きにして食べる人や
そういう人にとっては美味しい
今日はいいネズミ見つかっちゃったと
今日はかなり肉ついているコウモリ1匹捕まれたと
ちょうどいいんだというふうに言うでしょう
だから その人にとっては
それはスカーウェーダナ
フォークで牛の肉食べる人にとっては
それはドゥッカ・ウェーダナだからね
ですから そこら辺にもやっぱりそうやって対照的になってしまっちゃいますから
とにかくそれでも個人個人で見れば
自分にとってはドゥッカ・ウェーダナ
ドゥッカ・ウェーダナですからね
自分にとっては嫌な気持ちは嫌な気持ちだから
そのように見てみる そうすると
どんな生命にもあるのは
ただそういうドゥッカかスッカかアドゥッカマスッカかという 3種類にも感情だけですということをわかってきますね
そこでスッカだけの魂がありえないんでしょう
なぜかというと スッカもああやって変化するもんだから
牛の肉食べる人にはコウモリの丸焼きはドゥッカだから
芋だけ食べてる人にはたまたまコウモリの丸焼き見つかっちゃったら
これすっごいご馳走でスッカだから
ですから 楽しい快楽感
喜悦感ということも ということも
絶対的な言葉ではありません
故に 絶対的にアーナンダだけの魂
どうやって存在するんですかね
それはこういう物事を観察してない
人々に智慧がない人には平気で言えることで
ただ みんな言ってるんだから言ってるだけで
物事を見てないんです
もうちょっと厳密に考えれば
何が苦か何がドッカかと
膝がルー麻痺で痛くてすごい苦しみだ
ドッカだと泣いてる人が心臓発作を起こす
そうするとその人は何言うんですか？膝の痛みは何のこともないんだと
これぐらいだったら幸せだと
心臓発作を起こす時の苦しみっていうのは
そういうものじゃないんです
ものすごいもうすごい痛みだから
だからそれぐらい痛み感じる人にとっては
ルー麻痺の痛みっていうのはもう何のこともないし
それで何の痛みも体にどこに痛みがない場合は
やっぱりルー麻痺で膝がすごく痛くて
しょうがない 本当に人生は苦しいんだ
暗いんだとかね 不幸だとかまた言い張ったりする
そういうことだから これはドッカですよと
これはスッカですよという風に
この絶対的には言えないものなんです
絶対的に独立して存在しないはずなんです
で それはもう全然人はわからない
人が苦しみを感じると
その苦しみを対照して楽しみを妄想する
だから人生生きることは苦しみだから
それに対照して魂が絶対的な至福ですよと推測して妄想する
だから その妄想過程見たっても
この対照的に物事を考えてるだけなんです
だからそれは高いということは低いということによって成り立つことと同じなんです
別に世の中で高いというものは存在してるわけじゃないんです
高いと言うためには低いということは必要なんです
だから高いということも
もっと高いものに比べると低くなってしまっちゃうんですね
だからどちらが高いんですかね
そうやって何か絶対的に独立してインディペンデントにという風に存在しないっていうことは分かってほしいんですね
それは因果法則っていうことなんですね
因果法則こそ真理ですよと
だから因果法則ってあって
そこに何か実体あるわけじゃないんです
高いっていうのは低いというものに依存して成り立ちますよっていうぐらいの話ですから
別にその話だけのことなんです
で そういうことですから
そこら辺は実践の世界でお釈迦様はとても簡単に
その膨大な智慧の世界をね
とても簡単に理解して体験してもらうために
自分の体に生まれてくる感覚がドッカ
スッカあるいはアドッカ
マスッカ その三つに分けてみなさいよと
で 他人のこともそうやって見てみなさいよと
人の苦しみを感じる時も
苦しい苦しいって思う人は
もっと大きい苦しみが出たら
前の苦しみが何のことないんだと
あれぐらいは楽なもんだと一致しちゃいますからね
他人のことも同じ見えてしまうでしょうに
そう もしその瞑想がうまくいったならば
今私が説明したぐらいの智慧が生まれてくるんです
なんだ そんなもんかと
それだけでも 世の中のありとあらゆるこの妄想
概念もとで作っている哲学やら思想やら信仰やら諸教やら
そういうものに対して何の執着もなく
ただの玩具の遊びですよということになるんです
だから人間のこの頭のね
こういう物事を理解できないっていうことは
このライフフェーズの偉大なるグルがいるでしょ
彼の話聞くとよくわかるんです
あの人は死んでないんだと
なんで死んでないんだ
それは定説ですから 病院に行ったら死んだと言うんだと
だから死んでないんだと
それは定説です あんた方は定説わからないかと
また何か聞いたら サイババとすごい仲良くしてるんでしょう
それはその通りだから言ってるんだと
でもサイババは先生に会ったこともないと言ってますけど
といったら ちょっと待ってて
あのね それはサイババの勝手ですと
そこであの父親を殺したあの女がマスコイに向けて
やっぱりこの国ではいまだに定説は通用しないっていうことですねとかね
定説って何ですかね ですから
そういう人々には このね
まあ私たちにはそんな偉大な人物に会う機会はないんだからね
で マスコミの人々も同じグループだからね
もう反論も何もできないし
何もわからないしね だから
そういう人に向かってね
あなたは完全たる病気だと
アホだと私は思いますよとかね
あんたは本当に生まれつきアホでしょうと
ったらその人は反対するでしょ
なんでそういうことを
それは定説だから あんた定説わからないかと
で 同じことを言ってあげれば
まあそれで終わっちゃうんですよ
問題は だから証拠出す必要ないんです
定説です だからまあ 何か自分が思ったものとかね
妄想したものとかね それはそれで正しい証拠を出せない場合は
もうその人は定説論を持ってくるんですね
それでまたその通りだと信じる
ものすごいグループがいること
テーラワーダを勉強するグループよりははるかに多い
ですから その人々の考え方とかね
そういうものはどういうものかと
何のことなく軽々とわかるんですよ
この感覚を観察と瞑想してみればね
ヴィパッサナーで自分に何があるかと
1時間 2時間ではなくて
1週間  2週  1ヶ月とか
じゃあ 1 年間感じてみてください
1 年間 自分の体の感覚は何が出てくるんですかと
出てくるどんな感覚であろうとも
苦 楽 不苦不楽 3つに分けられるだけで
故に苦と不楽と不苦不楽が存在するかというと
それまたぐるぐる変わっちゃいますから
自分でもわかるでしょうに
ある時は苦と楽と言った感覚には今は苦と言うんだと
で 禅定の説明では これははっきり書いてるんですね
普通の俗世間次元でいる人が第一禅定を作ったら
俗世間の中で今まで味わってきたありとあらゆる楽しみ
五欲の世界は純粋たる苦だと
音楽やら他の異性と遊ぶことやら
もう何から何までもう世の中の遊びがあれは純粋たる苦でしたと
この第一禅定で自分が今味わっている楽しみが
ものすごい優れている幸福
幸せだと思っちゃうんです
でも その同じ人は第一禅定に至る前に
あれは楽しい これは楽しいとあったでしょうに
そこで第一禅定から心に思考が残っているんだからね
さらに瞑想して心の思考をやめてもらっちゃうんですね
第二禅定に行くんですね
そうすると その人は第一禅定っていうのはあれは苦しみですよと
と言うんです だから禅定ばっかりやったっても
智慧の方が開発しませんだから
それでまたより高いレベルの楽しみを目指すだけになっちゃいますからね
最終的に第四禅定っていうのは不苦不楽の感覚なんですね
ほとんどウペッカーだけになっちゃうんですね
それはウペッカーだけ感じる人は
スッカ楽しみを感じることは苦しみだと思っちゃうんです
だから第三禅定にあるのは
ものすごい苦しみ 楽しみだけなんです
ただ単に純粋に喜悦感だけ残っている心に
それだけ流れている それでもっと高いレベルないかと瞑想しちゃうと
第四禅定に入っちゃうんですね
第四禅定に入っちゃったら
あの純粋にあった喜悦感も消えちゃうんです
何もなくなっちゃうんです
感じるものは シャだけ
不苦不楽だけ それその人
これは一番良くて あの喜悦感っていうのは
あれ苦しみですよと レベルが低いんだと
と言っちゃいますね それでその人はこれでこの瞑想をやってみたら
あるのは苦と楽と不苦不楽だけですと
それもぐるぐる変わっちゃいますと
ラベルが 自分が付けるラベリングも
それでも対照的であって
もう何のこともないということはわかるんですね
そこを全然研究していない人にとっては
偉大なる天国 天国に偉大なる神がいるとか
そちらには偉大なる楽しみがあると
永遠があるとか 何でも考えられますよ
それは全て物事を観察しない人の頭の中で生まれてくる妄想にしか何もないんです
そこでみんな起こるのは
いえ いろいろ証拠あるんじゃないかと
もう確かにありますよ
例えば私がバラの花を見て
これはもう何でしたっけ
アンコウの顔を見た同じだと
思ったら それ証拠あるでしょうに
これあるんだから 逆に綺麗だと
そこでなんとかの証拠はありますよ
そこを見て何を妄想するかっていうことなんですね
だから神が本当にいるんだという人々も
何か経験はしていますよ
それ我々と毎日日常茶飯事の経験なんです
ある人に聞いたところで
どこか行ったところで車事故を起こしちゃったと
そこは自分がかすり傷もなくもう助かったと
故に神がいると言うんですね
ある人がどこか行ったら
いきなり足が滑っちゃって
もう何か穴に落ちたみたいですね
落ちたところで すぐ神をお祈りする言葉が口に出ちゃったんですね
そこでちょっと光のようなもの見えちゃったんだと
その人は故に頑固と神を信じているんです
だからその人にすれば証拠はあるんですね
私にすれば証拠何もないんです
そちらに 誰でもそういう突然事故を起こしちゃうと
もう星見ます そこでずっとそういう宗教的な暗示かけられてあったならば
その宗教の解釈する 科学的にしかものを語らないと思っている
解剖学とかいろんなものについてたくさん本書いてる
結構頭のいいそうそう人がいるでしょ
彼の頭の中でどれぐらい幻覚働いてるかと私にもジリジリと見えるんですね
彼がすごい科学的に客観的に見ているつもりなんですけど
そう見てないんです 本当のところは
結局幻覚を探していくんです
臨死体験がある人々を探して研究したりとかね
どういうことか だから彼にも結論が出せないんですね
もし まあ読んでみて下さい
もし今までの瞑想でいろいろ経験あるとするならば
すぐ見えるんです ここら辺はこういう幻覚
身元ついての解釈だと
でも彼は結構もう厳密に科学的ですけどね
なかなかなもんですけどね
決して捨てたもんではないんだけど
でもその中でもあるということなんです
他の人の本と比べると
もうすごいもう大したもんですけどね
うん  そういうことだから
あの まあ十というヴェーダナーっていうものを見てみたら
うん もう結構大体このヴィパッサナー瞑想はこのヴェーダナーのところでもう悟りに至るはずなんです
先行く必要ないんです
カーヤだけではいかないかも
ヴェーダナーの方に行ったらもう全ての妄想概念消えてしまう可能性はありますけど
うん だから今日からはこのチッタ
心の 心っていうそういうものが
あの 本当は見にくいんですよ
ですから この順番で他の瞑想をとことんやってみて
カーヤのね 瞑想 体の瞑想の方がね
すごくやってみて それから感覚はすぐに簡単にできるようになってくるし
それもやってきて かなり心の集中力もできてきて
余裕ができたところで
あのチッタの瞑想はできるんですね
それでもチッタという心というそのものがあの見つからないんです
で 見つから 見つからないというより
見つからないわけではないんだけど
なんか観察しにくいところあります
それ隠れているわけじゃなくて
この知る機能だから だから知る機能は機能ですよ
知る主体ではなくて この言葉を厳密に理解してください
知る機能 知るという主体ではないんです
この知るという機能はいつでもあるものでしょうに
目で知る 耳で知る 体で知る
脳細胞で知ってる 知る
ただの機能だからそれは
実体でも何でもないんです
だから我々はいろんなものに名付けているのは機能で名付けているんですよ
別に本来として何かあるわけだからじゃないんです
でも人間というのは機能を持ち出して物があると勘違いする
ギリシアの哲学者たちみたいに
椅子というものは存在しません
人間から見て ある働きが
ある働きが そのあるものがしているんですね
だから椅子と言うんです
机と言わない 椅子というものには
皿とも言わないんです
これは皿ではなくて机ですよと
これは皿ではなくて椅子ですよと
なぜ言うんですかね あれ機能で言うんです
皿と名付けるものがやる仕事が椅子というものにはできません
わかりますかね？機能ということ
このラベリングするということは機能なんですね
だからすごく大事なことなんです
実体があるわけではなくて
この機能は大事ですよと
例えば何かのテープレコーダーですと言うでしょう
なぜテープレコーダーと言うんですか？なぜサブトンと言わないの？機能でしょ
なぜ似ている部品を集めているのに
テレビを見て あ これもテープレコーダーですと
部品は似ているんだからと言わないでしょ
全然言わない 機能違いますから
ですから 実際にあるのは機能
機能だからあると言ったってまた意味がないんですね
その点でも あの実体として何か存在するというのはおかしいと
何か存在する言った途端
何か機能があるということだけなんですね
機能というものはあまりにもいい加減で
耳があるということは聞こえるという機能なんですけど
聞こえない時もあります
時計が聞こえなくなる場合もありますね
そうすると耳という必要はないんです
でも人間が耳が聞こえなくなったっても耳と言っちゃいますからね
それは言語の使い方であって
それ以上何もあるわけじゃないんです
それはですから 言葉の使い方ということを理解してほしい
だから私という言葉をお釈迦様は使います
それはただLANGUAGEの問題で
そうでないと文法的に語れない
それはほんのちょっとの道具であって
それまたある一つの機能なんですね
それも だから言葉に意味があると思っちゃう
思う人々はもう大変なもう妄想に陥って苦労します
[咳払い]初めは言葉ありきと言っちゃったら
もう初めからの無明ありきとですね
[咳払い]永久的に知恵が出てこないと
[咳払い][咳]で そういうことだから
このヴィパッサナーでこのずっとこのパジャナティ
パジャナという言葉が出てきて
このラベリングするんです
ラベリングすることと一緒に
この機能っていうことも
[咳払い]理解してほしい
手とか足とかいろいろラベリングするでしょうね
それは機能なんです だから間違わないんです
足に間違って手とは言わないんです
でも左右間違うでしょ？歩く瞑想すると
何でしょうか なぜ間違うんですかね
皆様方は真面目に瞑想の中で間違ったことないんですか？私は間違ったことものすごいあります
時々ちゃんと集中力あるんだけど
どちらが左かどっちが右か全然もう気にしない時もあります
皆様の経験どうかわかりませんだけど
大体が間違いますけど
でも左右間違って間違う瞑想する人が足と手が間違ったことがあります？手を挙げる
手を挙げてます 挙げてますって間違って足を挙げてます
挙げてますと言ったことが一度もありますか？ないと思います
だからもうみんな瞑想はしてるんだけど
なんで知恵だけは出てこないかという
それ私にも不思議なんですけど
それぐらいのこと知恵が出るはずなんです
じゃあ答えてみてください
なんで左と道が左と右が間違って
手と足は全然間違わない
いくら焦っていても 瞑想中も力もなくなっちゃって嫌になってきて
まあいい加減でやっていると
そういう時もあるでしょうに
もうやるんだからやってるんだと
そういういい加減に確認する時でも
手と足は間違わないんです
左右は間違う なぜ  歩くという機能を間違えて
私が聞いてるのはなぜ左？だから左足上げますと言いながら右足上げてる場合いくらでもありますね
そこをなぜ間違えますかと
上げます 下げますを間違えませんよ
時々そちら間違う時ありますけど
それはまあちょっと落ち着きがない時だけで
落ち着きがあっても間違う時があります
簡単ですよ 答えは 私から答え聞いたら
その点で知恵が開発することはもう鍵
他のところで頑張らなくちゃいけない
結局説法を聞くっていうことはね
時に私の話を聞くっていうことは
あんまりいいことじゃないかもしれません
もう普通の説法では絶対聞こえない
聞くことできないとこはもう全部もうバンバン言っちゃいますからね
左と右と間違うのは左と右は存在しないだからなんです
そういう機能がないだからなんです
左という機能がありますか？ないんでしょう
右という機能はないんです
答えが出ないのは機能があると思ってました
だから左と右の機能はあるから
だから言葉あるんだからといって
全ての言葉に機能があるわけじゃないんです
足といったらその機能なんです
左足と言ったところでちょっとおかしいんです
世の中で我々は左と右と言うんだけど
足だけじゃない いろんなものに左
右あるんですね 建物にも左
右あるんだけど 足がないでしょ
足には機能があるけれど
左足とついた場合には機能はないと
いえ 足には機能ありますよ
だから左という機能はない
ない ただの言葉 ただの言葉だからどっちでもいいんですよ
頭には 左でも右でも 頭にとってはどっちでもいいんです
頭の脳細胞にととしては
実際に左という機能はなし
右という機能はない  左と右は同じと見てもいいんですね
左も右もないから  同じとも言えないでしょ
ないものには  先生 頭にとっては時間もないもと同じなんですか？ そう
知恵遅れの人っていうのは
右も左も別に関係ないじゃないですか
機能がない  まあ大体ね
知恵遅れの人の場合はかなりこのたくさんの言葉がないでしょ
その言葉チェックしてみてください
大体いらん言葉なんです
ないのは で 持ってる言葉っていうのは本当に必要な言葉なんです
大体子供にでも左と右と教えてあげるのは大変ですよ
あれ存在しないものだから
大変なんです 知恵遅れの問題じゃないで
私の問題でもありますから
私に姉と母が左と右を教えるためにかなり苦労したんだから
私がちっちゃい時 もう 1歳 2歳あたりでもうすごく苦労して考える
なんでですかと で 今も覚えてるんで
そこはすごく苦労してたんだ自分も
大人が言うことを聞かなくちゃいけないし
で 言う通りに言わなきゃもう大変でしょうし
といっても どちらが左でどちらが右かと
時々このもう我々の場合はもうそれ左
右としてはいろいろありますからね
ご飯は手で食べるでしょうし
手で食べるんだったら右手で食べなくちゃいけないんですね
左 左手でご飯食べ触ることさえもすごい行儀が悪いとと思ってるし
それで右手で食べなさいよと
左手で触るんじゃないよと
どんな手ですかねと だから子供にはどんな手でも使えるでしょ
小さい時に ものを掴む場合は左手でもいいし
右手でもいいし そこら辺にある手使う
だからご飯 はい ご飯食べなさいと言ったら
この手で何かやってるんだったら
もう残ってる手でやっちゃおうと
後でどんどん脳にそれをインプットしてインプットして
我々は左利きになるか右利きになるかということになっちゃいますけどね
初めて字を教えようとしたと
教えとしたところで じゃあ鉛筆なんか取りなさいったら
もうサッともう空いてる手で取っちゃうんですね
それでもう準備OK もう書くために
え？違いますよ その手じゃなくてこの手だよと
で いきなり何なのかと
この方が便利なのにと
で そういうことで結構大人が苦労したんです
私の場合も この左と右の区別を教えるために
いまだに意味がわからないんです
どちらが左 どちらが右かと
それ存在しないんです
そうやってあの存在しないもの言葉たくさんあります
実際の機能にかけた言葉もあります
だからそこを言語学的な意味を考えて
大変な哲学でしょ でもヴィパッサナー実践でもう最も簡単にその智慧をね
経験させようしているんですね
実際の経験にラベリングしなさいと
妄想するなと 解釈するなと
痛みだったら痛み なんで痛いだろうとくだらんことを考えるなと
考えちゃうとこの巨大な智慧が出てこないんです
偉そうにこういうわけで
こういうわけで 気の流れが悪くなっちゃって
陰と陽の組み合わせが変になって
まあこうなりましたとかね
そんなことをやっちゃうと永久的に無知のまんまなんです
この問題は絶対解決しないんです
だから瞑想すると痛い
痛みだったら痛み それで終わり
それは機能ですから 自分が体が弱いんだから痛いんだとかね
言われた途端ものすごい気持ち悪くなるんです私が
なぜ気持ち悪い あんまりにも頭の悪さに
で 私にとっては私にも時間ないし
早く死んじゃうし だからもう聞く人がね
これは二十年計画でやってほしくないんです
もう聞く人がね これは二十年計画でやってほしくないんです
ゆっくりのんびり一人がもう二十年計画で瞑想しちゃうと
私にとってはもうその何人かにしか教えることはできないでしょうに
だから一日 二日で理解しなさいと
理解してもう二度と来るなと
迷惑だから という気持ちだから
やっぱりこれはもう百年も頑張らなきゃってことでしょ
冗談抜きに僕は人にやっぱりこの人にはもう百年もダメやとかね
ありますよ そこを自分でそうやって考えちゃうと気持ち悪くなるしか [笑い]無駄やとかね
まあですから やっぱり訳があって言ってるんですよ
逆に言う通りにやってくださいと言っちゃったら
なんとなくね 新興宗教みたいに命令したんだから
ブッダの言葉だからっていう風には言いたくはないんだけど
そういうことでもなくて
もう真理だからということも言いたいし
だからすごいもう人間の頭で理解できないこの真理の世界だから
そこに至るためにも そういう方法でやらなくちゃあかんでしょうに
だから訳があって言ってるんです
じゃあ訳言ってくれと言ったってももうわからないでしょうに
[咳]だから頑張ってみてください
仏教は論理的ですよ 結局
最終的にもやっぱり論理的でしたとわかるんです
やっぱりすごい論理的でしたと
そういうことだから この言葉には問題ありますから
このテープレコーダーといえば
これは我々間違わないんです
テープレコーダーはいくらでもテレビでも間違わないし
なぜならばこれくらい大きさのテレビもあるでしょう
でも絶対間違わないんです
それは機能だから左右は間違う
またそう言って間違うことはいっぱいあります
人の名前 間違わない 存在しないんです
でもそれには人間がどれほど引っかかっているかというと
家の名前とか ああだこうだいろんなことを
人の名前を書くが 漢字でも間違っちゃったらすごい失礼だそうです
大阪大学にいる時は最初にそれを教えてあげたくれたんです
もうみんなあなた方に
外人の人々 人々にね 日本人と名前はほとんど似てるんではないかと
みんな同じ名前ではないかと
ほとんど同じ名前の発音の人いるでしょうね
でもあれ 発音同じですけど
漢字が違うんだと 字が違うんだと
だから我々から見れば
この発音が一番大事なんですね
それで例えば新井という名前があるんですね
で それでその人が新井という風な言うためにどんな漢字使うかと
そこは気をつけなさいと
発音が間違ってもいいんだと
新井とか言わないでシンニさんだと言っても
相手が失礼だと思わないんだと
シンニさんですねと言ったら
別にあんまり機嫌が悪くならないんだと
違います 新井ですけどと言うかもしれませんと
でも新井と言って違う漢字だけは書くなと
もう新井という他の漢字があるでしょう
それだけは書くなというと
本当に我々外国人にとってはやっぱり何なのかということはありますよ
ですから まあそれは別にどうったことない話なんですけど
人の名前も結局は存在しません
名前はないんです だから名前間違っちゃうんです
だからみんな大体は皆様方頭いいんだからね
人の名前を覚えていますけど
私はほとんど名前を覚えていませんだけど
かなりしつこく私といろいろやりとりやらない限りは名前を覚えております
でもそれはこちらの問題で
皆様方は名前は簡単に覚えているよとか思ってるんだけど
なんでいろんなところでみんな名札付けてるんですかね
どこへ行ったって それは証拠でしょうに
もし田中さんとか新井さんとか中村さんとかね
シンイチさんとかシンニさんとか
いろいろ人に名前があるならば名札は入れませんよ
誰かが私は女ですよと名札をつけたことがありますか？間違ったら困りますからと
ないでしょうに 1万  2万人に一人ぐらいとかはいるんだけど
あれは特別で それだけでわかるんだからね
この人はものすごいすごい男みたいにいるんだけど
本当は女ですよと みんな知ってるんだから問題ないんです
なぜ人が男ですと女ですと書かない
その代わりに名前だけ書く
例えば小学生とかね 例えば幼稚園とかね
子供たちのジャケットに名前書いてますけど
女男は書いてないでしょ？書く必要ないんです
わかりますかね 言葉の問題は
だから存在しないものはする
すぐ頭からすぐ滑っちゃうんです
私もある子供にも年賀状出したくて
子供はものすごい徹底的に知っていってるんだけど
名前を忘れてる だからどうしようかとも困って困って
聞けないでしょうに 聞いたらまた失礼し
もう一回二回怒られたこともあるし
一回手紙が来て偉そうでね
母の名前はこれで 私の名前はこれで
妹の名前はこれですと
もう説教されたんです
それなのに忘れちゃった
だから今大変 私はもう今もうものすごい悩んでるんです
どうやってこの名前調べようかなと
大人よりはね 年賀状っていうのはやっぱり子供に出すもんだからね
子供にとってはそれですごい面白いことだからね
意味がありますよね ですから
名前っていうのはね 存在しないんだから忘れちゃう
だけど私はその人のことを忘れたい
それじゃない それ逆 ものすごく覚えてます
でも名前忘れる すぐ滑っちゃう
そうやって研究してみてください
実際に存在する言葉と実際にない言葉っていうのは
で なんでそこまでいらんことを喋ったんでしょうかね
それはまあ 心の問題で
心っていうのは機能です
知る機能 知る機能だから言葉一つしかないんです
たくさん言葉がないんです
知る その機能だけだから
そうすると心にたくさんの言葉使いたければ
何を知る心かと言わなくちゃいけないんですね
これ難しい じゃあ例で言います
フォークといえばフォークでしょ
1種類しかないんです
でも 何を食べるフォークかっていうことで
あるでしょ 果物を食べる時の使うフォークやらね
フォークには色々種類があります
それは何を食べるかっていうことによって種類があるんであって
結局はフォークはフォークなんです
ナイフも同じでしょ ナイフもナイフ
でも何を切るということによって種類が出てきます
中華包丁っていうものがあって
それは物事をものすごいぶつ切りにするんだったらそれ使うと
果物ナイフというものがありまして
それは軽くて細くて 果物の皮を剥くために使うと
だから果物ナイフあるという風に言っちゃうんです
[背景音楽]そうやって切るものによってナイフはいろいろ
でも実際はナイフは一つです
切る 機能 ものを切る 分ける
それはナイフです だったら一種類しかない
でも切るものでもって強引にたくさんあるようにすることはできます
それ強引ですよ なぜ強引かというと
じゃあみかん みかんじゃなくリンゴの皮を剥く場合は果物のナイフ使うでしょ
あれは絶対中華包丁でできないかというとできるでしょうに
じゃあ刺身用のナイフで包丁でリンゴの皮を剥けない？剥けるでしょうに
だからただ強引だけ 強引だからみんなそれ知ってますよ
リンゴを持ったらこれ皮むいて食べなくちゃいけないな
あの この家で果物のナイフないね
だから食べられないんだ
残念ですという人がいますか？全然一人もいません
何かナイフ持ってきてと
何でもいいんです だから実際我々はやってますよ
そういうことは ですから
ナイフといえば一種類
皿といえば種類なんです
でも何を入れるかということによって
皿はいろいろ 心といえば一種類
ですから 何を知るかということによっていろいろですが
それはそんなに大変大事なことではありません
例えばアビダンマでは心は八十九種類あると言ってるでしょ
大事なことじゃないんです
あれは何を知るかということによって八十九にしているんです
だからそれは包丁は八十九種類ありますよということと同じなんです
ですから 見るということは知るということでしょう
だからチャック・ヴィンニャーナと言うんです
聞くということは知るということでしょう
音を知る それにソート・ヴィンニャーナと言うんです
耳識と言うんですね 香りをわかったということは知ったことでしょう
だから鼻識と言うんです
体で寒さやら温かみやら感じることはカーヤ・ヴィンニャーナ
身識 頭で何か知ることは意識と言うんですね
だから六識が出ちゃうんです
別に六識あるわけじゃないんです
識 それだけ 何を知るかと
まあそれぐらいで ほどほどで止まらないとキリがないんです
例えば この人女の人ですよと知ることも知ることでしょう
それに一つの色眼と女の人を知る心
男の人を知る心 子供の子供を知る心
おにぎりを知る心とか
キリがありますかね 青い色を知る心
赤い色を知る心 冗談じゃないで
それだったら なんだかんだ我々に区別できますから
このカーテンまるっきり同じものです
やっぱりそれでも頑張って見ると
左側のカーテンと右側のカーテンの差が見つかるでしょうに
そうすると心は二つでしょうね
左側のカーテンを知る心と右側のカーテンを知る心
まあもう冗談じゃないんです
やりきれなくなっちゃう
だからもう眼耳鼻舌身意
止まった方が論理的で
まあいいんじゃないかなということになるんです
だからブッダの言葉は乗り越えられません
結局は それを全部考えておいて言葉をかけているんです
ですから 心ということは知るということだから
瞑想にならないんですね
だってずっと知っているんだから
いろんなことを 瞑想しようとしても
音が入るは妄想が それはすべて知ることだからね
足が痛くなってくるわ
全部自分知ってるでしょうに
だから知ってるんだ 知ってるんだ
知ってるんだ 知ってるんだって
瞑想になりますか？バカになるだけなんです
座って知ってるんです
朝原の瞑想と同じ 座って瞑想します
瞑想します 瞑想します
瞑想 朝ずっと徹夜してそれやるんです
足を組んで たまたま飛んでみるんです
それと南無妙法蓮華経南無妙法蓮華経と言うのは同じなんですね
ただ最近かないか？あの夜
あの黒澤明さんの何か映画があって
トテツ電のなんとかというタイトルでしたけどね
古い映画で ん？トテツ加電
あれ見て ああ 黒澤明っていうのはすごい奴だなと再認識したんです
で 一つ一つの画面でこの訴えていることはすっごい深いんですね
で 一番最初に笑っちゃったのは
この一人 よく出た人で
この精神的におかしい人がトテツ加電とは電車で頑張ってるキャラクターですけどね
もうただ口でトテツ加電
トテツ加電 トテツ加電で毎日毎日もうちゃんと電車を運転する
頭だけで もう拭いたり
いろんなことをもうもうちゃんと洗っておきなさいと言ったのにとかね
もう人だから はたから見ればこの人病気
精神的な病気なんですね
その人の母親が朝一所懸命南無妙法蓮華経南無妙法蓮華経とお祈りしてるんですね
お祈りして 結局は自分の息子はなんとかしてちょうだいとね
お願いしてるでしょうね
おそらく そこは我々から見れば常識なんですね
それで あの子も母親がああいう風にやってると
南無妙法蓮華経 南無妙法蓮華経
南無妙法蓮華経とものすごい大きい声で言って
どうか仏さんお願いします
お母様のことをよろしくお願いしますと言うんです
で お母様にも南無妙法蓮華経言えなくなっちゃうんですね
だから 母親から見れば
子供は精神的な病気で
障害者で困ってるんですね
逆に子供はお母さんのことをよろしくお願いしますと
それを南無妙法蓮華経じゃなくて南無妙法蓮華経
南無妙法蓮華経 だから
あのポイントだけ見てもすごいことなんです
私の目で見れば どちらが狂ってるかで
どちらでも狂ってるでしょうに
狂っていると言えば 正気ではどちらでも正気なんです
だから 子供から見れば母親が狂っていてね
すごい悩んでる だから子供として心配
だからお母さんのことをお願いしますと
母親から見れば子供が頭狂っちゃってもう心配とという話なんですね
ほんのちょっとの場面なんですけど
人間のね もう世界っていうのはちゃんと描いてるんだからね
すごいもんなんですね
それだけでもずっとそういうことをもうずっと続けて続けて
終わりまで人もう一つ負けないぐらいのもう内容あったんですけどね
それは別に他の映画を見てないんです
で 他のものもリストも見ようかなと思ったんだけども
できなかったし で あれだけ見たんですから
だからそれだけ言うんだけどね
他の映画もっといいかもしれませんし
もっと悪いかもしれない
分かりません まあ  そういうことで
まあとにかくこの心っていうのは知る機能で
知る機能だけ知ってるんだ知ってるんだ知ってるんだっていうのをヴィパッサナー瞑想になりません
ただ何か音みたいに何か繰り返して繰り返して言うだけになっちゃうだけですね
だからこれヴィパッサナー瞑想っていうのは本当に無知がもう無知を破って智慧開発するための具体的なやり方だから
いい加減なものじゃないんだから
だからこちらでやり方
誰にでもできる簡単なやり方をお釈迦様はおっしゃっているんです
あのとてつもない智慧が単純な方法でわかるんです
それでイデビッケベビク サラーガンワーチッタン サラーガンチッタンティパジャーナ
で サラーガっていうのは欲があるということで
だから心っていうのは知ることだからそれを言うんです
別に それじゃなくて 瞑想していると
なんとなく心にいろいろ欲が出てくる
いろんな欲の汚れが出て
欲のことを思い浮かんだりする
何のことなく 今サラベチッタだと
今は欲の心ですと確認する
それは正しいやり方で知ってるんだ
知ってるんだっていうことじゃないんです
ずっと知ってるんだから瞑想にならないんです
だからある時の自分の心がに欲が生まれちゃう
欲が生まれたら今欲の心ですと
ということは欲を知る心ということなんですけどね
それはそこまで行く必要ないんです
今欲の心ですと それで欲の心ですよと言っていると
もう心っていうのは無常だから
次に違うことを知ろうとするでしょ
だから包丁と同じく もうもう違うものを違う名前入れれば入れればいいんです
それで欲の心ですと言ってるとこで
当然欲っていうのはもう消えるんだからね
ずっとあるわけじゃないんだから
次にヴィータラーガンチッタン ヴィータラーガンチッタンテパジャーナって
心欲から離れちゃったら
今欲から離れた心ですと
その時の心 自分が完全に欲からなくならなくてもいいんです
欲といったっても 我々は生まれた瞬間から死ぬ瞬間までずっと欲だけの流れでいくわけじゃないんだから
ぐるぐるぐるぐるいろんな心が生まれるんだから
ですから ある時間ですぐ欲が生まれてくる
それを今欲の心ですと
それは次のことを知ろうとすると
もう欲がないかもしれませんね
それで欲が消えてるんです
その時は今欲がない心ですと
これも例で分かりやすいと思います
ある若い男の人がいて
すごい綺麗な女の子が道路で見たら
すごい綺麗な人だと思ったら欲が生まれるでしょうね
それで見ていて 次に側見たら
そこにすごい汚い服を着てホームレスのおじいさんが座っていると
こういう女の人を見ていて
かっこいい女の人だな
ホームレスだなって そこで欲ありますか？同じ感情
あれ見ただけで すぐちょっと心が変わるでしょうね
ですから 同じ欲でずっといるわけじゃなくて
心というのは知ることだから
この知るものによって欲があったり
怒りがあったりとか それでぐるぐるぐるぐる変わっていっちゃうんですね
憎しみが起きたり 嫉妬が起きたり
強烈な欲が生まれたり
軽く欲が生まれたり で見る知るものによりますよ
あるものを見て ああいいですねと
それで俺も軽い欲 あるものすごいですねとかね
それもちょっと強い欲とかね
あるものを見たら あ これすごいですね
あんたどこで どこでこれ買ったんですかね
私にも教えてくださいとかね
それもうちょっと欲が強いでしょうね
またあるものを見て あーこれいいですね
私にちょうだいちょうだいちょうだいよと言ってねだると
それもっと強い欲でしょうに
自分で行って買おうともしない
そのものを奪いたくなるとか
ですから 見るものによっても生まれる欲を色々色々変わって怒りも同じでしょうに
あぁ嫌だ うるさいんだったあんたは
とかね それも怒りでしょうしね
うるさいんだよと それも怒りでしょうに
こんちくしょうともっとちょっと怒り
もっとすごいでしょうに
それで悪口言ったりする
すごい また怒りでしょうね
ぶん殴ったりもする もっと怒りが強いでしょうに
相手を殺したりもする
それでもっとすごい怒りでしょうに
だから見る聞くものによって
もう色々色々心が生まれて変わってはいく
そこをチェックしてみるんです
コントロールするでも何でもなく
ただその過程をチェックするんです
で カッコつけて立派な人間になれそうと思ったら
もう悟れませんよ それ自我だから
その過程を見てくださいと
何が起きてもどうったことないと
見るたびに見るものによって欲が色々欲が生まれる
色んな形の怒りが生まれる
聞くものについても 色んな形の欲が生まれて
色んな形の怒りが生まれたりする
だからコントロールしようと怒らないようにするんだ
欲が出ないようにするんだという人はちょっと無理でしょうね
智慧が生まれてこないんですね
きつくついんですよ 出るも出るんだからね
コントロールしようしたってね
智慧がない限りは 前ウェーダナで説明したような智慧が生まれてない限りは
もう出る妄想の世界だから
幻覚の世界だから だからまず過程を見てくると
そんなもんかということをわかってきますね
そういうことだから なぜ私は説明しましたって言うと
皆様に関係ないんだけど
注釈書を説明すると聞くともっと違うことを言うんですね
ヴィーターラーガン・チッタンというのは
もう煩悩なくなった清らかな心ですよと
それはもう悟った人の心です
ですから 一向にヴィパッサナーする人にも
それは瞑想できなくなっちゃうんです
だからヴィーターラーガンという言葉を悟った人の心に使います
ラーガが消えた心 欲が消えた心と
それで我々も瞑想しようと
ヴィパッサティ瞑想しようと思ったところで
じゃあこれから心の瞑想するんだと思ったら
サーラーガン・チッタンは瞑想できます
ヴィーターラーガン・チッタンは一向にできないでしょうに
だから私はこの伝統的な注釈書の話ではなくて
もっと実践的である心で欲が生まれたら
次の心には欲がないということになっちゃうんですよ
次といって次の次でも
なくて ある やっぱり自分に欲があるんだと気づくとも結構時間かかってるでしょ
これは欲だとわかるともう時間かかってますからね
そこで ある一定の時間経ったところで
欲あるいは消えちゃったっていうことも見えるでしょう
だから欲がちょっとちょっと前の欲がもう消えちゃった
今消えちゃったということで
今は欲がないと その瞬間の心だけ確認するんです
私の心に欲がないということじゃなくて
今欲のない心ね もうちょっと時間経つと
また欲の心が出てくるかもしれません
そういう風に確認するんですね
その怒りの方なんですけど
電車の中でこう人がこう
なんか寄っかかってきて
自分の中で嫌だなと思ったら怒りだなという状態で
そこで変えて ああ 疲れてる
この人は疲れてるんだなとか
そういう風に自分の中で変えちゃいけないんですか？もっと見るんですか？そういう風に見ることによって
結構それなりに  まあ別にそれは別なことでね
それは別にどうってことないと思いますけどね
それとこれは関係ないようにも感じがしますけどね
だから自分が他の考え方を作って
怒りの心を止めたっていうことですからね
止めたんだからってまた現れないという約束ないでしょうし
だからこちらでは あ 今は怒りの心
今は怒りが消えちゃったと見るだけで
実生活の中でもこれは管理した方がいいでしょうね
怒りを放っておくとかね
それはいいわけじゃないでしょうしね
放っておいちゃったらすぐ膨張して増えますからね
感情っていうのは瞬時に繁殖するでしょ
放っておけばどんな感情でも
悪い感情はね いい感情は放っておけば消えますけど
悪い感情は放っておけばどんどんどんどん増える
それは心がそれに慣れてるんだからなんです
ですから そんななぜ悪い感情だけどんどん増えていって
いい感情はすぐ消えちゃうんですかと
という疑問が生まれるですよね
やっぱり世の中で悪魔いるんじゃないかとかね
誘惑するとかね そういう話じゃなくて
同じ法則なんです 慣れてないんですね
良い感情に 無欲の感情に
慈しみの感情に 慣れているのは自分が偉いと
他人が偉くないという感情なんですね
それはずーっとそれで慣れていたんだから
放っておけばその自我の感情が成長する
それで心育てて 慈しみの感情も慣れてしまっちゃったら
無欲の感情も慣れてしまっちゃったら
それもずっと成長する
それに慣れちゃうと 貪瞋痴の感情はもうほとんど自然滅失
自然死だからね 正反対だからね
怒りと慈しみってのは正反対でしょうし
欲と無欲っていうのは正反対でしょうし
だから一つ成長すると
もう一つは自然死になっちゃうんです
だから貪瞋痴消えちゃったら
もう努力しなくたって放っておいた方がいいんです
心は 貪瞋痴も生まれてこないし
だから放っておいたって
もう別に布団不尽愚痴のもう感情で流れてしまっちゃうんです
そういうことで 細野さん聞いてるのは
この日常生活の中で そうやっていい方向へ感情をコントロールするのは悪いかっていう質問だから
それは悪くないんです
で こちらで言っているのは
どのように心見るべきかということなんですね
自分の心を その時はいろいろいじる必要はないんです
いじる必要ないということは放っておけということ
放っておいてないんだから
もう観察しているんだからね
でも日常生活する中でも
いつでもこの観察する能力さえあれば
もう最高にいいんです
観察する能力ない人がコントロールした方がいいんです
悟ったということは 常に観察能力の中にいるんですね
だったら ある人が体に寄ってきたら
この人体に寄ってくる
ただそれで終わっちゃうんですね
体に寄りかかった 思いた
で 私も座っていると 時々人が寝てね
体にどんどんどんどん寄りかかってくるとね
いや 困ったもんだなと思った
別に気持ち悪くはなりませんだけど
で 困るのはもう女の人が居眠りして
どんどんもう体に 寄ってくるとね
その時はもう自分がいつでももういたずらばっかり考えちゃいますから
で 寄ってくると線立っちゃえばいいねとか
それでバタンと食べちゃいますからと
それ自分にとって面白くなっちゃうんですね
それでもそれやったらあかんと
やったらまあ先生だあかんでしょうしね
かわいそうでね まあこんなの女の子が
まあ一応もうそんなもんでね
だから本当に必要なのはこの常に先がある心なんですけど
まあそれはまあたくさん実践していただければいいし
うん  先生いいですか  はい
私はあの金人知老婆動作毛髪でサティしてきましたけれども
あの老婆で老婆とサティしますと
私はありがたいことにすぐ消えてくれましたね
その消えたことは私分かったんですが
消えたことはサティしなかったんですね
うん  でも時間的に余裕がありそうですから
今のこの離れた心というサティした方がいいですか？ そうそう
老婆が消えたら 老婆が消えた心ですとサティをするんです
自分ではもちろん消えてくれる
消えてくれるって分かってたんですけれど
あのラベリングをしませんでした
ちゃんとラベリングしないと知恵が半分になっちゃうんです
で すぐにサドーサンワーチッタン
怒り 心に怒りが生まれたら
今怒りの心ですと確認する
で 次に怒りが消えちゃう
あ 今怒りが消えたところですと
で 確認する で 次に 3番目サモハンワーチッタン
今無知な心ですと 今心に
今無知がある心ですと
そこを観察しちゃうと
すぐ無知っていうものは消えちゃうんですね
しっかりするんですね
心 それで あ 今無知が消えた心ですと
あの次のセット サンキッタンワーチッタンサンキッタンチッタン・テパジャーナ
サンキッタンっていうのは小さくなるっていう意味なんですね
日本語は何でしたっけ？金人知終わったところ
委縮した心 縮まった心
縮まった心って何ですかね
そういう感じがないんだよ
どんどん何か自分が小さくなってきて
やる気がなくなることなんですね
見たくないと やりたくないと
あるいは見ようともするんだけど
なんかもうエネルギーがないと
心の機能が低下してるような状態
そこはまあ一般的にごく普通にありますよね
やる気がある時もやる気がないと
まあ大体それぐらいのことなんですね
はい そこで例えば確認はするんだけど
なんかもう膨らみ縮み
あそこ あ 心は小さくなってるんだと
萎縮しているんだと 膨らみと縮みというと萎縮してないんですね
ちゃんと確認する時はね
だからそういう変化も心に起こるんですよ
認識する知る機能なんですけど
しっかり知る まあまあいい加減で中途半端に知るとかね
あれ知るエネルギーなんですね
すごくエネルギー絞って知るか
中途半端で知るかと でもこちらはサンキッタンチッタンの反対はヴィキッタンチッタンなんですけど
これはちょっと意味が違う
力強ってみてもないんです
日本訳は何でしたっけ
散乱した心  散乱した心ですね
ですからこのそこであのいい方向じゃないんです
あの知るエネルギーはなくなっちゃって
小さくなってくる心と
もう何か何だか分からなくても散乱している状態と
いわゆる分かれ道も あれも知って
これも知って これも知って
どうしようか どうしようか
どちらを選び直せればいいかという状態なんですね
音も入っちゃうし 膨らみ縮みもわかっちゃうし
足のあちも痛いし どうすればいいんですかね
その場合は その場合は心が散乱しているんですね
でもその場合はちゃんと一つ一つわかっている状態なんです
わかっているけれども
たくさんありすぎてついていけないという心の状態なんです
うーん これ別に答える必要ないと思いますけどね
まあ一応本人にとしてはわかっているつもりなんですね
膨らみ縮みと同時に音も
で また空気は冷たいことも同時にわかっているんだというつもりなんですが
散乱する心なんです とにかく
そういう状態って 心の状態が希薄になってしまったような時の気分がするんです
で どんどん進むと昏睡に
あまりこのいいか悪いか判断する場合はね
それほどいい状態じゃないんです
とっととやっぱり昏睡睡眠が出てきちゃいますからね
その状態と次は ですから
よくわかっているんだっていうことではないんですね
本人はそう思ってるんです
だからちょっと答えにくいし
答える必要ないんです
そのポイントには  集中の反対として捉えていいんだ
そうですね 散乱だから
集中っていうのは 1つのものをしっかり知ることだからね
全部同時に知るっていうことは集中の反対なんです
集中の度合いが薄れてくる
広がるというか いい例に
広がるという やっぱり散乱でいいんですよ
結局はね 広がると言ったら
すごい何でもかっこいい言葉になっちゃいますけど
結局散乱してもうすぐ昏睡睡眠必ず来ますよ
だからこの具体的にみんな瞑想する場合は
みんな言われるのはいつでも言葉で確認しなくちゃいけないんですか？と
そしたら私はなんでそんなことを聞くんですか？と
わざと聞くんで まあ知ってはいるんだけど
逆に質問を出すんですね
なんでそんなこと聞くんですか？と
いい 時々音も入ってきて
膨らみ縮みわかっていて
私は言葉かけるのは面倒くさいんだと
ただ感じておけばそれだけで十分ではないかと
すごいかすかそうに答えるんです
その答え欲しくてあの質問を出すんです
そこでやってみなさいと
あんたはすぐに昏睡睡眠ですよ
間違いなく  言葉なしに
じゃあ感じているんだ
感じているんだと  そういうことです
次の心はマハッガタンワーチッタン
マハッガタンチッタン
それでマハッガタンっていうのは大きくなった心
それは広めた心っていう言葉でいいんですね
もう大きくなった これはすごく心強くなったんですね
散乱の心じゃないんです
よくわかるんです すごい元気なんですよ
でもそれは集中力の方
いわゆる厳密に膨らむを感じて確認できると
もう何の苦労もなしに明確に感じると
心はあっちこっち音があるかもうばったりもうわからない
痛みなんかもうどうったことないと
もう感じようともしない
もうすごく見ることはすごく見えると
それ巨大化になってるんですね
心は巨大になってるんですね
巨大になってることと散乱してるっていうのは随分違うんです
逆に言えばすごいやる気が出ますね
その時はすごい元気なんです
心がすごい力があるんです
心には力あります そこでアマハッガタンワチッタン
あんまり巨大化になってない心と言われ
普通の心だと それも瞬間瞬間起きますよ
時々この瞬間抜群に確認できる時もありまして
あ すごく上手にできるもんだなとわかるでしょうに
あまり長持ちはしません
それも その時は あ 今マハッガタ心だと
巨大心だと そこで次にもうちょっと一分二分で
まあ普通にもう痛み膨らみ縮みになっちゃうんですね
あ また心はアマハッガタン
巨大化になってない心だと見るんですね
で サウッタランチッタン
ってどんな訳？ 有上の心を
有上の心であると知る
有上の心と無上の心ですかね
その次は無上  こちらの方
有上も無上とパーリ語でもちょっと混乱しますけど
サウッタランっていうのはなんか自分が上達しているような感じなんですね
心は上達 今は結構瞑想上達しているんだと
あれ気持ちよく嫌々なしにやれる
それはサウッタラン 無上っていうのは
そんなにすごく上手になったわけでもない
上達したという気持ちもない
それもその瞬間 その瞬間変わっちゃうんですね
ああ よくできそうなっていう
なんか瞑想簡単にできそうなということもあって
まあそうでもないかと
という風にも思ったりもする
だから同じ十分間でそんなこといっぱい起きますよ
次にサマーヒタンチッタン
アサマーヒタンチッタンというセット
サマーヒタンというのはサマーディができた心
サマーディができたっていうことは
この第一禅定二禅定とかね
そこまで行かなくてもいいんです
そこまで大体ヴィパッサナーで行けませんから
大変な仕事だからね それでも一つにちゃんと集中できて
他のものはもう消えちゃうんですね
サマーディという世界では集中だから
一つするんだから 包丁に例えてみてください
包丁でリンゴを剥いている時はキャベツは切れないでしょうに
だから心も同じく一つの仕事しかできないんです
でも一時一時間のことをまとめてみたら
ある人が台所でいろんなものを切っていたんだと
大根も切って それからキャベツもみじん切りで
それからもう何でしたっけ
玉ねぎも切って それからもうサッサッサっともうもう皮を剥いて
リンゴの それからまたもうジャガイモもいろいろやりましたと
包丁でいろんなことをやりましたと
1時間まとめたら言えますけど
同時にはやりません 一つも
リンゴとジャガイモを 2つ手に持って皮を剥くっていうことは無理だから
ですから 知るのは一つだけなんですね
だから我々の時間感覚ないんだから
すごく遅くて鈍いんだから
もう同時に聞いて見ているんだと勘違いします
それはそれとしょうがないんだけど
どんどん瞑想し続けると
一つだけ見続けると集中力が生まれてきて
それだけ見える 膨らみだと言った途端
他のものはあることさえも知らない
で 縮みと言ったところで縮みがあるんであって
他のものはないと というと
もうサマーディがあるんです
そこは 1 分  1 分ぐらい続けちゃうとすごい経験なんです
あ 消えたと勘違いする場合もあります
体が消えちゃったとかね
で そういう風なことであって
すごい顔をして私に聞くんですね
そう ある日瞑想すると
ある瞬間全部消えてしまったと
それだけで止まるので
それは私の口から じゃあそうですか
それはあなたは本当に悟りに至ってありがとうございますと言ってくれるだろうと
だけど ああそうと言って終わっちゃうんですね
それからなかなか私と人間関係悪くなっちゃうんです
で それから遠慮して遠慮してもう下がるんです
どうしようもないんですけど
私にとっては だからあまり延々と説明しちゃうと
本人も瞑想中解釈するでしょうし
だから説明してあげてはいけません
褒めちゃったらとんでもないことになる
悟ってでもなんでもないのに
本人にもとんでもないことになって
私もすごい罪を犯したことになっちゃう
人の悟りの道を邪魔したんだから
人を脅せたんだから 機嫌取ろうと
それはもう絶対悪人にしかできない仕事だからね
だから良かったとは言えないし
何も言えないんだけどね
まあまあ そういうことにもなりますけど
一応瞬間で 例えば膨らみだけ見えたと
その瞬間で他のものは見えないんです
もう消えてるんです 本人の解釈で消えたという解釈になるんです
でも真面目に道場に入って集中的に瞑想すると我々にはありますよ
質問リスト で その質問を聞けば
まあ本人が気づくんです
だからそうやって一つのものを見えた瞬間はサマーディ
心はサマーディの瞬間を得たんだと
次には膨らみ縮むだけじゃなくて
足も組んでいるんだっていうことをわかっちゃうんだから
今はサマーディではありませんと
前の心はサマーディの心
今の心は普通の子と確認すればいいんです
次にヴィムッタン・ヴァー・チッタン
ヴィムッタン・チッタン・ティパジャナータ
アイムッタン・ヴァー・チッタン
アイムッタン・チッタン・ティパジャナータ
ヴィムッタンというのは解脱した心なんですね
訳は？ そのように  うん
だからそこでちょっとトラブルがあるんですよ
私の心が解脱しましたと
今解脱している心だと一向に確認できないでしょうに
だからその訳ではないんです
だからこちらで時々心から貪瞋痴は全部なくなって
もう何もない 解脱したかのごとく何の心波もなく膨らみある
だから何をと縮んでるのだから何をと
色々現れて消えていると
そんなもんよ だから何をという風な気持ちにはなります
それもなんとなく この何て言いますか
解脱の擬態状態 擬制擬態何でしたっけ？擬似体験みたいなもんなんですね
でも決して解脱ではありませんだけど
でもその時心には貪瞋痴がない
前はむさぼりがあってむさぼりがなくなった
怒りがあって怒りがなくなったことで
今はそういうどちらでもなくて
全部ない状態 貪瞋痴全部
だから貪瞋痴全くない心での結構生まれますよ
瞑想中 まあまあ  2 3週間ぐらいやって頑張って経験を積み重ねていくと
まあ生まれて 最初は生まれませんだけどね
まあ時々私はあまりにも強引にこのもう瞬時に作って見せる時もありますけど
そこで瞑想した人がびっくりしている
でもそんな瞬間でびっくりしたんだからってうまくいくわけじゃないんだから
それから一人でやらなくちゃいけないんだから
私はもう助けるのは一回きりだからね
その時ももうたまにちょっとちょっと力入れて
いろんなことで心をコントロールしちゃって
ジャックをしなさいと
で やった 1分以内で心からサッと貪瞋痴が消えちゃうと
で どうですか？言ったら
本人もやっぱりすごくびっくりするんですね
なんと安らぎの心でしたかと
そういうのは一時的なことで
瞑想し続けるとなんと安らぎとかね
何もないんだと そこで今
ヴィムッタンチッタンと
解脱の心と言えばいいかわかりませんだけど
もう解放した心という言葉でいいんですね
今解放した心だと そこで色々感情が貪瞋痴も不貪不瞋痴も生まれてくると解放されてないんですね
やっぱり引っかかってるんだからね
今は解放してない心だと確認する
それぐらいのセットで十分でしょうということでしょうね
だから貪瞋痴で言えば六つ
それからサンキッタウィッキット
萎縮した心と散乱した心
そこで 8つ それからマハッガタアマハッガタ
巨大化になった心 小さくなった心と
いわゆるすごい力ある心と力がない心と
そこで 10種類になるんですね
それから上達したと上達してないという風に出てくる波
そこで 12になっちゃう
で 次にこのサマーディが出たり引いたりする状態
それで 14になりますね
それから解放したことと解放しなかった感覚ですね
14になります  16になります
大体それぐらいに分ければいいんです
そちらにもお釈迦様のもうちょっと裏で狙いがある
ここに使ってる単語は全部もう解脱者の心に使う単語を使ってるんですよ
だからそういう単語で瞑想続けちゃうと
間違いなく解脱の方向にいってしまっちゃうんです
最初は解脱してないんだけど
ほとんど疑似体験みたいなもんで
どんどんどんどん本当に心から貪瞋痴
本当に消えた瞬間でも
あ 貪瞋痴が消えたとわかるんです
だからこういう言葉使ってるんです
他の言葉使えばよかったのに
パーリ語だったらそれそういう願いなんです
だから私は解脱した心の代わりに解放した心使ったんだけど
それでもいいんですよ
あ 解放しちゃったという気持ちになっちゃいますからね
そういう確認の経験があると
もう悟りは間違わないんですね
悟りだと誤解はしません
やっぱりもう消えちゃったんだから消えたんだと
もうないんだと 我々のファスもないんだとわかるんですよ
ただ 無常で見たものは
やっぱり無常ではないと後で見えるはずがないでしょうに
間違ってでも ですからしっかりと分かりますから
そういう あの 狙いというより
これはものすごい計画なんです
もう想像を絶する計画なんです
この十六に分けて こういう風に見てくださいということ
だからいまだに私にも想像できないんですね
お釈迦様はどうやってここまで客観的に心分析で学者の超学者でしょうし
よくもこうやってセットして作っちゃったんだから
なぜならば お釈迦様はもう自分で悟る
突然瞑想 中道的な方法を見つかって突然削除したんだから
お釈迦様にとっては方法なかったはずなんですね
もう悟った もうしょうがないと
こんなこと言ったっても意味がないんだからやめましたと
こういうことだから それで後からお釈迦様がちゃんとどうすればこの心
こういう人々の心が解脱
この方向へ持ってこられるかという
この道順を だからあれすごもうとんとつもない知恵というか
もう理解能力なんですね
だから我々は まあブッダの知恵には勝る知恵がない
本当に勝る知恵がないんです
誰にもできない こういう風に作る
瞑想法を作るということは
もし私の解釈でサティパッターナ経典を読んで
それからヨーガ・スートラであろうか
どんな瞑想のテキストであろうか
もう関係なく読んでみてください
こんなに深く深く考えてないということはすぐ見える
でもヨーガ・スートラの方がもっと難しいんですよ
読みにくい これはすごい速合で
なんだ簡単単純じゃないかとわかると思えるように書いてるところもまたすごいところなんです
できるように書いてるんだから
実践できるように 誰にでも
はい そのように自分の心のいろんな波を見る
いろんな波なんですけど
一応十六種類ぐらいに分けておいた方がやりやすくて
今 包丁を見ている心だと
今はカラスの音を聞いてると心だと言って瞑想にならないんでしょうし
それだったら極普通で終わっちゃいますから
あるいは知ってるんだ知ってるんだと言っちゃったら
波法礼経と同じくなっちゃいますからね
何もならない それはどちらでも取らないでちゃんと分けてみようと
分けるところでも やっぱり人間に扱いやすいぐらいの種類に分けて十六種類ですね
こちらでは 分けてしているんですね
それから自分の心だけではダメなんですね
いろんな人の心もそのように観察する
で 他人の心も観察し続けちゃうと
ものすごい能力が生まれてくるんです
不思議と同じものなんですよ
だから人の心も萎縮していると見えるでしょうし
あ 今萎縮している だから自分の萎縮している心も一回見たんだから
あ 今この人の心が萎縮しているんだと
あ 今萎縮していないんだと
今なんか力があるそうで
巨大化になって 今はそうじゃないんだとかね
そういう能力で まあ人の心もちゃんと読めるというかね
わかると だから人の心わかり読めるというのはそんなレベルなんですね
そうではないと人の心はちゃんと読める特別な魔術持ってるとかね
そんなくだらない妄想を読めたってもどうったことないんだからね
あの人何考えてるんですか？とかね
何の役にも立たない そういう世の中で言ってる人の心を読む技っていうのは何の役にも立たないもの
だから何なのかと じゃなくて
この過程 その変化してるプロセスを見られると
その見られる人には他人にも教えてあげることもできるし
そうやって自分の心 他人の心と両方見たら
やっぱり心っていうのはそういう風に働いてる
まあ過程であってね 別に絶対的な心あるわけじゃないんだと
知る機能だからね 知る機能も様々で
時々もう散乱して知る
時々巨大化になって知る
時々萎縮されちゃってなんとなく知るとかね
時々ずっとサマーディになって知るとかね
いろいろな方向で知るんだと
で 時々怒りがあったり
時々欲があったり 時々怒りが消えたり
時々欲が消えたりとか
まあそんなに勢いで変化している機能だけだから
心に対する執着も まあ心何なのかと
これっていう という気持ちにはなるんですね
なんだこれかと で そういう気持ちでも
また解脱の世界が出てきますね
そのように心のことを観察します
以上です  [背景音楽]